[Music]
hi I'm Jen hi I'm Sam we're working out
of the New York office for a few days
and we both are interested in pizza and
we're both from Chicago I forgot to say
that I'm also from the suburbs that's
okay okay but we have both have really
strong opinions about pizza so we're
gonna do a New York Pizza taste test
which is really just Chicagoans complain
about pizza in New York
it's ladylike and we're gonna eat some
[ __ ] pizza we don't really know much
about New York but Freddie lived in York
for a long time yeah and so she's gonna
tell us three different piece of places
that we should check out to get a real
taste of New York Pizza yeah she's also
back in the LA office so we gotta go
Skype her yeah but it's light where she
is where it's dark here calm Freddy
gonna call finish I'm ready
hi Freddy what's up this is the premise
we want to taste some good good good New
York Pizza people super super fabulous
in the village okay and then in Caesars
in Soho okay
time's a thing but really worth it what
makes New York Pizza good Freddie in
your opinion I think what makes New York
Pizza it's just like the size slices you
get for your life
thanks red thanks Bill thanks for your
advice
right two brothers pizza or two pros P
because we're going to go get to boot up
and see how to the dollar science man I
respect one dollar slice these look
really Bob to be honest yeah - gosh yeah
I will say this pizza is very much like
kind of like toast it's kind of like a
crispy toast with like some tomato sauce
and like really good cheese because it's
thin crust is much less going for a
dollar
I love Rufus I will maybe approve your
pizza for $1 yeah let's go
throw it out
[Music]
why is she run like
there's an artichoke on the side
when you were eating pizza what are you
looking for I like to be able to taste
like a lot of cheese and the sauce the
sauce is so important okay tomato sauce
is so important
I'm a toes are amazing oh yeah so this
is the artichoke pizza from from
artichoke pizza yeah we should point out
look how thick this pizza is Oh what is
the pizza pie emphasis on the pies kind
of tastes like a chicken pot pie to me a
really good chicken pot pie with like
delicious crust the last things we
pretty much gobbled it down I don't
think I can finish this it's very
filling it's still really good as a
pizza we're traditionalist as a pie I
think it's like a fruit now listen if
you want something different and new try
homosexuality but also this pizza it's
very different than Chicago style pizza
but I say like I understand why people
in New York are really loyal to their
pizza yeah it does have a certain like
character yeah and you can stand it's
portable it's cheap it's on the go
that's the thing Chicago pizza is like
with your family sitting down like yeah
this fork and knife like that you can
saturate it in a big box and the reason
we're going next we're going to famous
Ben's pizzeria
now this is recommended by no one else
but Freddie Freddie
this is Freddie's trophy but I mean this
looks more like a Chicago pizza than
anything we've seen so far yeah it looks
like there's a lot more sauce and cheese
on this pizza than there were on the
previous pieces definitely sauce and
definitely more crust
dick Freddie crust it's got some girth
to it the funny thing is I wasn't even
really hungry at all when we got here
you know but I want to eat this whole
pit you can taste the cheese and then
you can also taste the tomato and spices
in the sauce this sauce is really a
tangy yeah and that's really good like
much oh it's a weed interior I'm sorry I
pay your dog the fact that this pizza
kinda reminds me of home is really good
and there was a wheaten terrier here
means that this is the greatest pizza
place in the world this is the most
amazing piece of leaded Illuminati's you
can't say that judge no but this is the
best pizza place in New York City okay
let's go with that
that was a pizza adventure I was a pizza
pizza there we go
nailed it all three places were good I
definitely think like we didn't come
across a bad slice tonight to me the
best one was the last one
the r-truth pizza was like a specialty
pizza interesting I liked it it was just
like so it was a pie really [ __ ] and I
think and we feel like very very heavy
afterwards but I will say that the two
bros $1 slice that like New York style
on the go was also really really good so
to me it's a little bit of a toss-up
we're Chicago girls so I think like fans
has to have it but truthfully like
comparing New York style pizza and
Chicago deep-dish it is like you can't
really do it you don't try and both and
then just like enjoy them though I try
not to anger any one side too much yeah
everyone come here please don't yell at
us and everyone from Chicago what's up
hey what's up
[Music]